inflexible et menaçante devant le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu la turquie
a de nouveau réaffirmé sa position sur
la situation à idlib le représentant
turc met en garde damas au carat
ripostera à toute nouvelle attaque
lancée par l'armée syrienne contre ses
positions
nous continuerons de répondre par tous
les moyens nécessaires comme l'a annoncé
le président erdogan la turquie frappera
tous les objectifs qui constituent une
menace immédiate ne retirerons pas nos
forces et nous n'abandonnerons pas nos
postes d'observation c'est le régime qui
doit se retirer de ses positions
actuelles jusqu'à la fin de ce mois de
son côté la russie tente toujours
d'apaiser les tensions entre turc et
syrien
moscou demande aux occidentaux d'
arrêter de protéger les groupes
terroristes
pour le représentant russe cette
démarche porte les souffrances de la
population civile
la fédération de russie comme d'autres
membres du conseil expriment ses
préoccupations concernant les conditions
de dizaines de milliers de déplacés
internes qui se sont retrouvés hors des
camps trouver une solution devrait être
la priorité absolue de la communauté
internationale en particulier compte
tenu de la période hivernale et du
nombre élevé de personnes vulnérables
dans ce contexte diplomatique tordu
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la syrie
guerre pedersen 10 rue douter une
nouvelle escalade des violences
les délégations russe et turc se sont
réunis à plusieurs reprises au cours des
derniers jours à ankara munich et moscou
il ya également eu des contacts au
niveau des présidents mais aucun accord
à ce stade n'a encore été conclu tout au
contraire des déclarations publiques des
différentes parties syriennes et
internationales laissent entendre un
risque imminent d'escaladé en attendant
des avancées diplomatiques les forces
gouvernementales syriennes continuent
leur progression est libre selon l'onu
près de 900 mille personnes ont été
déplacées depuis le 1er décembre dernier
[Musique]